on va parler d'une question absolument
existentielle et je pense qu'elle peut
elle peut peut-être apporter quelques
solutions à certains d'entre vous et je
ne vise personne n'est ce pas damien est
ce qu'il vous est arrivé parfois ça peut
arriver compris lorsqu'on est jeune
d'avoir des petits soucis de libido des
moments où ça marche moins bien
oui moi c'est comme un médicament c'est
matin midi et soir donc j'ai aucun bon
d'écouter en tout cas d' aventure il
venait y avoir des petits moments un peu
moins festif que d'autres voient là bas
il ya une possibilité ça s'appelle la
une cure par les plantes et certaines
d'entre elles sont vraiment reconnues
pour leurs vertus aphrodisiaques ces
halos docteur vous explique tout cela
depuis la nuit des temps
les plantes sont utilisées pour leurs
vertus aphrodisiaques
parmi les plus connus il y a bien sûr le
ginseng techland qui va aider le corps à
s'adapter qui va stimuler ce qui est
laid à la sexualité aux performances
autre plan pour booster la libido la
damian nature nairas aphrodisiaques à en
dit long sur ses propriétés
traditionnellement donne plus aux hommes
qui souffrent d'éjaculation précoce et
d'impuissance à tout âge ça on peut en
donner même un petit jeune de 30 ans qui
a une panne parce qu'il est un peu
émotif un peu tracassé et qui sent que
ça marche plutôt bien damian en général
ça va bien de soutenir mais certains
rebelles naturelles sont exclusivement
réservés aux femmes comme le chatte
avarie en sanskrit ça veut dire la femme
aux mille mari donc c'est dire voilà et
la liste est encore longue
alors qu'est ce qu'on en pense d'abord
je vais me tourner vers le médecin est
ce que ces plantes visiblement sur ce
plateau on nous dit oui les plantes ont
des réelles vertus aphrodisiaques sont
des médecins qui confirme c'est vrai oui
alors c'est pas une expérience
personnelle mais c'est plutôt à présent
cortese bon clarifier les choses les
esprits mal placé et en fait il faut
différencier deux choses dans les
troubles de la libido
les troubles de la libido de l'homme de
plus de 50 ans il ya également un
problème mécanique hormonal et qui a
besoin de parme de testostérone haute et
kiara besoin de la vraie pilule la
petite pilule bleue avoir une érection
avoir rapporté des autres troubles de la
libido qu'on peut se voir à 25 30 ans
plein d'autres choses est lié par
exemple fatigue exactement un coup
d'angoise est donc là ces plantes là ont
une vertu parce que elles vont diminuer
l'anxiété
elles vont permettent de se relaxer un
petit peu et donc de favoriser la libido
donc c'est un mécanisme indirects que
d'accord donc il faut il faut distinguer
avant 50 ans après cinq ans la tâche à
quel âge par exemple passe au tutoiement
parfois j'utilise des périphrases
parfois je suis extrêmement 12 dans les
parfums en voyage va être très clair
patauge t'emmerde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé mais obtenue par secret médical
dont je ne crois pas en dieu c'est
justement est-ce que vous avez été je ne
sais pas les merengues et autres
pourquoi vouloir stimuler la libido si
elle se trouve dans les chaussettes âge
laissons faire la nature enfin vous
allez pas si paralysée par hasard par
malheur vous avez une période un peu
plus compliqué vous avez pas rester un
mois deux mois six mois un enfant
j'accepterai le fait que mon ramoneur ne
veuille plus s'inviter dans le conduit
de cheminée vous invite à écouter
après une journée et dias damien vous
n'êtes pas seul peut être que votre
votre moins attachés
j'ai causés mais passera trois fois non
mais voyez la libido ça ne concerne pas
que vous ça conservées dans l'huile
c'est vrai mais à un moment donné
pourquoi je me sacrifierai si je n'ai
pas envie mais eric s'avère que si j'ai
une journée de boulot stressant
il va de soi que je préfère ma allongé
sur le lit que sur maman vraiment mais
vraiment il faudrait quoi la relation 7
certaines femmes parce que vraiment elle
a du mérite on va lui donner une petite
médaille on va inventer la médaille de
ces que de la télé un truc vraiment pour
si big up
oui départ on a eu les discours très
rôdée très professionnelle de jimmy très
gênée de deux amis âgés dans vgg non il
faut vraiment comme si de rien n'était
comme si ça n'existait pas et j'aime
bien tourner autour du pot faut se dire
un truc est très claire on est tous tous
oui à mon mental est soumis à une baisse
de libido
voilà ah bon bah oui bien sûr pour
amener d'accord c'est vrai la raison ça
me fout d'eux parce que c'est à moi
parce que je vous trouve
particulièrement voilà je ne trouve pas
de mal il n'y a pas de mal à se
commandent hier à sybille se stimuler sa
libido mais vous par exemple d'être bd
dbt aux plantes des influences qui est
important c'est de faire lecture de
trois mois il faut que ça et c'est le
docteur ithurbide qu'ils parlent
maintenant je vais peut-être prendre
l'ordonnancé moi je crois beaucoup aux
macaques et le ginseng péruvien par
exemple ça marche allez on a vu alors
antoine griezmann le thé aux macaques
hyproc qui planait tiens donc les mânes
aurait des accords l'objet d'un viol le
mât cassé il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent très bien les huîtres ça
fonctionne très bien avec une légende
urbaine sa non non je vous jure frein
après ça je pense que ça dépend de
l'organisme de chacun mais en tout cas
qu'on arrête de se voiler la face la
baisse de libido bout les écoutes a
ouvert quelque chose les volumes c'est
un marché énorme émoi il faut pas
grand-chose
abb qu' on est tous soumis à un moment
donné à une baisse de libido il faut pas
s'en cacher d'accord at on est condamné
on dit bah si ça arrive on laisse passer
à lille ce soir à dijon ce soir on n'est
pas seuls dans la dans la galère
d'accord c'est bien le genre de débat
totalement sinon on se retrouve après
tout seul dans la galère moi jamais moi
en galère jamais madame heureux sommes
franchement prendre des plantes pour
booster sa libido je le fais je pourrais
le faire au ridicule
ah je pourrais faire à 43% mais ridicule
à 55% 2% seulement 11 et dire que
c'était un tout petit peu par par des
produits bon peut coûter il n'ya pas de
mal non plus n'y a pas de montant banon
voilà où un petit et